how are you i'd kiss you all but
you know there's a virus thank you very
much oh
what a crowd thank you you're so good to
thank you thank you you have my utmost
appreciation
for uh you know testing and all this
stuff you had to get
you must have nothing better to do i
really appreciate you doing this i
really do
and you're in a terrific mood must be
because it's valentine's day weekend
are you excited every everybody oh my
gosh
everyone's in the mood army hammer told
his girlfriend today i'd eat you all
over again
it was
but it's hard uh in lockdown right
valentine's day
it's hard to be romantic yeah i said to
someone the other day let me get that
refrigerator door for you
i'm trying to be oh it took but i tell
you
yeah we're halfway through february i
still can't wait for last year to be
over what the [ __ ] i thought this was
going to be a better year
and and i tell you
valentine's day nothing gets you revved
up for romance
like a solid week of bloody insurrection
videos huh
were you watching the impeachment all
week i it's uh
just about ending yeah
the democrats of course laid out a very
powerful case uh that trump
incited a violent insurrection against
his own government
and the republicans laid out today a
very powerful case
uh that they don't give a [ __ ] that's
that's yeah
yeah they they really don't i mean have
you seen their lawyers
whoever was i mean it's pretty pathetic
one of them though is an observant jew
although he thinks trump is innocent so
not that observant
and and um but some of the
i mean the video they were smart to just
show the video let the tapes do the
talking and uh there's some amazing
stuff there
including a hero that officer uh eugene
goodman the guy who who
you know he really saved pelosi and mitt
romney he turned around and got him
going the right way and
and mike pence they were going to hang
mike pence
and he said quick mr pence your people
are revolting and penn said no they're
just suffering economic anxiety
all right um but here's what i love
about this
trump fans are still claiming that the
people in the video even though they're
wearing trump hats and trump shirts and
carrying trump signs
and beating on trump targets with trump
flags
reading trump tweets are actually antifa
really that's their defense it wasn't us
it's people dressed up like
us acting like us
[Applause]
i tell you that antifa school for the
performing arts is one
hell of a dramatic college they they are
really good wow
i know that this was pretty funny it
came out today that during the whole
impeachment trial really since trump's
been out of the white house
melania has spent most of her time at
the spa
her favorite relaxation passage is the
silent treatment
that's uh
also it's the chinese new year
oh wow why
why why are we so excited people like
the chinese
okay great and listen china china has
got an arrest
in every way and they have an unmanned
chinese spacecraft now that is orbiting
mars
its mission is to land a rover on the
surface and look for signs of ancient
life
and then cough on it and kill it
and uh
also they're not the only ones i'll tell
you we're getting america poor america
uh there's a spacecraft now from the
united arab emirates that's also entered
the mars orbit and its goal is to make
contact with intelligent alien life
and make sure the women cover their
faces that's their goal
uh and
our friend marjorie taylor green you
know her right
she's in the news okay the now this is
the from the daily mail i'm only
reporting what they're reporting
they're saying that she cheated she was
caught cheating on her husband
she used to at the gym she used to run a
gym
that was her job before she was in
congress
she ran a [ __ ] gym in alpharetta
georgia and one of the guys she
apparently allegedly had an affair with
was a polyamorous tantric sex guru
something tells me that alpharetta
georgia a tantric sex guru
is any man who's heard of the clitoris
i think that's what that means i mean
please tantric sex guru you mean some
guy you met on tinder who [ __ ] you on
a yoga mat
that's what they're talking about and uh
but it's currently caused a lot of
trouble in the home there for marjorie
taylor
the husband found out when she came home
one night with lube on her straight
jacket so that was bad
and that and then also the daily mail
says she was having an affair not just
with the tantric sex guru but with the
manager of the gym
and you know that's bad to have have a
affair with the gym manager because
you're all gung-ho at first and then
after a
few weeks you stopped coming
you